Some time ago, I decided to go visit a good friend of mine on a university campus.
While I was there, I thought, you know what?
I'm going to go catch up with another couple friends of mine who are atheists and
see if we can have a good conversation about God, faith, and the big questions of
life. And we had a great conversation.
And I remember a question one of my friends asked me.
He was actually a PhD student in physics.
He just looked at me and he said, how can you possibly believe in miracles?
I said well tell me why you ask what's your problem with miracles he said how can
you believe in a miracle such as a resurrection that somebody can rise from the dead
when science shows that people who die stay dead this student
expressed a common belief that many skeptics have namely that somehow miracles
violate the laws of science as popular as this objection may be it's based
on a misunderstanding of the intersection between science and between faith.
Here's why. Scientists aim to explain certain features of the natural world.
They do this by observing some patterns and then drawing the most natural inference.
In this case, when people die they stay dead.
Death is final. But the resurrection is not a claim that Jesus
rose naturally. The resurrection is a claim that Jesus rose supernaturally
that God stepped into the world he stepped into history to perform a miracle
namely the raising of Jesus from the dead which was the effect which could not have
happened if the world was left to operate according to its normal processes alone
this student was dismissing that any powers beyond the natural world could act
within the natural world he limited explanations for things we see in the world
to the regular patterns we observe around us.
But this is a mistaken way of thinking and in fact it brings us quite obviously to
the duck-billed platypus.
At the end of the 18th century, the Western world first encountered the duck-billed
platypus. It's a rabbit sized furry animal that lays eggs.
It's got a duck bill, quite obviously because of its name.
it has webbed feet and it's native to Australia.
If you happen to see one be careful and watch out for its venomous claw.
Back then Europeans were stunned even at the sight of a hide of a platypus.
Many refused to believe that such an animal was possible but it wasn't until 1884
when a platypus mother was shot and she had just given birth and then they
found another egg inside of her.
It was only at that point that some people began to believe.
Why were so many people, including many scientists, hesitant to believe?
The problem was not a lack of evidence.
They had the fur and the testimony of their colleagues who had seen the platypus.
You see, the problem was on the level of their worldview, their belief system about
reality. You see, their worldview said, either you have mammals who give
birth to live young or you have reptiles who lay eggs.
It's not possible to have a mammal who lays eggs.
And in this case when they were presented with evidence for that very thing because
of their world view they dismissed it outright.
This is how many people approach the miraculous.
If they haven't seen it and it doesn't fit certain preconceived categories, then
they dismiss it. It must be a hoax even when presented with evidence for
miracles because of assumptions from their world view many people simply don't even
consider that it could be true. And in fact they leave no room for the supernatural.
That's why the question of the possibility of miracles really depends upon the
existence of God. if God doesn't exist then of course miracles are impossible
but if God does exist then miracles can happen and this puts a
huge burden of proof upon the skeptic the skeptic actually has to show that
God doesn't exist because if he even just possibly exists then the miraculous
can happen so here's the bottom line just as the scientists in the day of the
platypus needed to be willing to follow evidence when it took them outside of their
preconceived ideas today skeptics need to be open to the evidence for the miraculous
and to follow the evidence wherever it leads but not only are miracles possible
we have good reason to believe that miracles actually happen today
whenever I speak to Christian audiences I often ask a question I'll simply ask the
question how many of you have seen or personally experienced the miraculous?
And I don't mean like you're going shopping during Christmas season and you happen
to get a lucky parking spot. I mean a supernatural miracle that can't be explained
purely in natural terms. And every time I do it, dozens of
hands go up. Friends, there are tons of living Christians today who believe
they have seen and experienced miracles and are willing to testify to that fact
in his massive academic study on miracles New Testament scholar
Craig Keener notes that there are hundreds of millions of Christians today that's
right hundreds of millions who believe they have personally experienced or witnessed
miracles the deaf being able to hear the blind regaining sight
and the lame being able to walk there are even cases reported of
the dead coming back to life. Professor Keener carefully and meticulously
documents these in his two-volume set on miracles.
There's simply no good reason to dismiss the possibility of miracles before
examining the evidence. And there is good reason to believe, as we have seen with so
many testimonies, that miracles actually happen still today.
Talking about miracles can raise a lot of questions.
Why does God perform some miracles, but not others?
Even in my own life, there's times that I've prayed and not seen the answer that I
was praying for. And that can bring doubts and that can bring questions.
But here's what I do know. I know that we worship a God who is powerful.
And as Psalm 77 says, which you will see in this week's verse, we worship and follow
a God who performs wonders today.
This is a God who performs miracles.